l'un des symboles de la vie des
banlieues pauvres l'un des exemples les
plus flagrants des erreurs immobilière
des années 60 est tombé en poussière et
en gravats à 13h07
aujourd'hui c'était à la courneuve dans
cette cité des 4000 cité dortoir où il
ya moins de trois ans rappelez vous un
petit garçon toufik avait été abattu par
un habitant qui ne supportaient plus de
l'entendre crier aujourd'hui l'un des
bâtiments a été détruit pour que naisse
un nouveau quartier et une nouvelle vie
reportage à la courneuve de gens payent
eux cinq quatre trois deux un feu
400 logements hlm 70 mille tonnes
l'immeuble debussy s'écroule mines et
d'explosifs il emporte avec lui les
stigmates d'un quartier à problèmes
j'habitais pendant quatre ans
qu'est ce que cela vous fait ben c'est
monstrueux et ça soulage
c'est un symbole démolition pour
détruire un immeuble de cette taille
une première en europe on a employé une
technique américaine celle de
l'implosion
les murs de plusieurs niveaux dont les
deux du bas sont découpées pour être
affaiblie on y place près de 3000
explosif qui agiront avec des
intervalles spécialement calculer car
l'opération n'est pas sans risque tout à
côté un autre immeuble qui selon la
méthode traditionnelle de sap aurait été
menacé par sa chute les ondes de choc
sont donc envoyés vers l'intérieur de
l'immeuble ce qui ajoutait à l'effet des
murs troués le fera s'effondrer sur lui
même une canalisation enfin court le
long de la barre on a montré des gravats
pour la protéger démolition réussi les
gravats déblayés
on aménagera ici des espaces verts avec
des maisons et de petits immeubles afin
de créer un nouveau quartier
c'est cela le pari de la démolition de
la courneuve